- You look very cute and beautiful.
You're tonal today.
Do you see how we're?
- [Kelly] Look, we didn't
even call each other.
- I know.
- Yes.
You were feeling earth tones.
I was feeling, how are your chickens?
Last time you were here we were
talking about your chickens.
- Let's get to the serious stuff.
- [Kelly] Let's just get right
to the nitty gritty, yes.
- Well, the chickens moved to
the family farm in Oklahoma.
- [Kelly] Oh.
My bunnies I talked to you
about, now live in Montana.
My ranch in Montana.
- [Jennifer] Okay.
- Yes, it's better for them.
- They're happier.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- And yes,
- [Kelly] Space.
- Each of them went
and I felt a little bit guilty about this,
but each of them went in
their own little to-go box.
I was a little bit like, don't think
too much about this chickens.
- Yeah, you're not nuggets, it's fine.
- Yeah, you're not a nugget.
- Yeah.
- And they all had a little
bit of food on the plane
with a little bit of Benadryl in there.
(audience laugh)
There's just a tiny bit of,
- Yeah, just a.
- I love that though,
- That's fun.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- Living on a farm, that's better.
- [Jennifer] Yes.
They don't lay eggs anymore.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They're postmenopausal.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- But you know what?
- The world doesn't
care about them anymore.
- I know.
But they still have value.
And they're still smart, lovely ladies.
- [Kelly] They're relevant.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] No, I have to ask this too,
because I just moved here and I love it.
- I'm so happy you love it.
Your kids like it?
- I love it, my kids love it.
- Good.
- [Kelly] We love it here.
But you moved here and
you were pretty young.
And what was that first move like?
- I moved here.
So I graduated from college.
I worked at a Shakespeare festival.
I was doing like summer stock
theater, you know, like,
you know, cleaning the toilets
and building the sets and all of this.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- And the Georgia Shakespeare
where I worked, there was
a musical there that went
to a strip mall in Florida
and I went with the musical.
And so I worked there.
And then I came up here to
audition for Utah Shakespeare.
You can tell I wanted to do like,
- Yeah.
- Be on stage.
- And when I got here, a friend said,
"Hey, here's a backstage,
you should go check this out."
So I checked it out.
I went on auditions.
I got three jobs that first day as like.
- Wow.
- I think I just walked in and I was like,
"Hi, my name's Jen."
"I'm from West Virginia, I like to act."
You know, I mean.
- I wanna do this.
- [Jennifer] They just kept being like,
"Okay, let's see what you can do."
So somebody said, "You
should meet with an agent."
Anyway, I ended up living here.
I was understudying a Turgenev play
'A Month in the Country'
at the roundabout.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I lived on a woman's kitchen floor.
A woman that I found
off the bulletin board
at Actor's Equity.
- As you do, as one does.
- [Jennifer] And there was
a futon in my suitcase.
- Yeah.
- And like tucked into the corner.
- [Kelly] I remember futons.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I lived there for nine months.
- A couch and a bed.
How awful is that?
- I never folded it up.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- It was just a little
mattress in the corner.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
No, I lived on a mattress
in someone's house in L.A.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- That was kind of similar.
I think when you have a big dream,
you just are willing to accept
whatever comes your way.
Like to get there, yeah.
- It didn't even phase me.
- Wait, honestly?
- I was thrilled.
- No, me too.
I was excited, that, is funny.
Looking back,
I'm just like, what in the world?
Like if my kid was
like, I'm gonna do this.
- Yeah.
- But I, at the time was just
like, living my best life.
- Yeah, it did not even occur to me
- to feel weird,
- That it was weird.
- That I was living.
No, I was thrilled.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I don't think,
I think we get too
precious about things now.
- Yeah.
- [Jennifer] And I had no money.
I couldn't afford the subway
token to get to Times Square.
I walked back and forth.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I made $150 a week
and I worked too much to do
real shifts at the restaurant.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And somehow I just
survived, I just made it work.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's awesome.
I love people hearing that too,
because you're so successful.
So those people killing it right now.
Like there is light at
the end of the tunnel,
you know, if you really put any time.
Well, you know what I think is,
enjoying the journey of it.
And letting yourself be where you are
not just looking ahead, looking ahead.
Like, I'll be happy when,
I'll be happy when I
get into this college,
or when I am married or when this happens,
or I must whatever.
I just was like pretty
psyched to be right there.
- So, whenever, whenever you
were talking about Shakespeare,
I heard, is that the cast
that you did laundry for?
- Is that, did you lose a bet?
- Oh gosh.
- Like I was like, you
did, you did laundry.
- Okay, so in the process of all of this,
when I worked at this strip mall.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was non-equity, but I
was an out of town person
and I think I was making just
like a hundred dollars a week.
- Oh.
- But it was, I was professionally acting.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- And I couldn't have
another job at the same time.
And so the owner of the theater, he said,
"Well, what are you gonna,
what are you gonna do?"
"How are you gonna afford
to live down here?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I said, "I can do anything."
"I can clean, I can do laundry."
- That's why you're successful.
You accepted any, like, I can work for it.
- Oh, it didn't even, I
just said, I can do laundry.
So there were 35 people in the cast,
most, 35 men in the cast.
And I washed and ironed
all 35 dress shirts
between every show, eight shows a week.
And I did that the whole time.
And he let me be a roommate
to another person in
one of the apartments.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- I'm glad people are hearing that too.
I was, 'cause you know why I,
whenever I run into, especially musicians,
- I can really iron a shirt a shirt.
- No, because I run
into certain musicians,
like, you know, throughout my
career and they're just like,
oh, I don't, I can't get a job.
I'm like, there's a Starbucks
right down the road,
like there's a Target, right.
Like, what are you doing?
And they're too proud to go get a job
that they think is beneath them.
And I'm like, do you know
where all I've worked?
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- Like, do you know
how many jobs I've had?
- I just, I feel lucky
that that wasn't in my way.
I didn't get in my own way,
- It wasn't in mine either.
- [Jennifer] And I
thought it was hilarious.
I mean, by the way, can I just
be real here for a second?
The amount of times I
sent 35 men on stage,
in slightly damp, very wrinkled shirts.
- [Kelly] Throw it in a
dryer with a damp towel.
- A crease at the wrong place.
I mean, I was just like, sorry.
I mean, I was 22.
- Yeah.
I don't think I could do it now.
I don't iron well, I'm never ironed.
Girl, I throw it in the
dryer with a damp towel.
Anyway, so you, gets
the wrinkle right out.
That was the look at her
new movie, 'Family Switch.'
You can catch it now on Netflix.
So explain, the movie's hilarious.
Explain to everybody what's going on.
- [Jennifer] Thank you,
the movie is so much fun.
It's really just, you know,
like all body switch movies,
it's about walking a mile
in someone else's shoes.
It's impossible to know what
your kids are going through,
what your parents are going through,
unless you can actually be them for a day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Jennifer] And it's, you
know, just a lot of fun.
Just in this case, we all switch.
Ed switches with Brady,
who plays our son, Brady Noon.
Ed Helms, Ed Helms.
- [Kelly] Yeah, love Ed.
Yeah, we love him.
- [Jennifer] The baby
and the dog switch too.
Just to add a little chaos.
So it's the most,
- That's my favorite part.
- And it has a little
bit of a holiday feel.
It's the most fun, heartwarming, funny.
If you have Ed Helms in
a movie, you're golden.
And by the way, these kids
outshine the two of us,
they are amazing.
Amazing.
- I love that.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Do you love playing moms?
Because I've seen you in a
lot of movies where you're playing a mom.
Do you love playing the mom role?
- I do.
- [Kelly] Because you do it well.
- I really do, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I must be working something out
because I keep playing mother, daughter.
- Yeah.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- No, it's awesome though.
We are, I'm telling you,
my family is obsessed.
Like 'Yes Day', I'm telling
that movie changed my
whole family dynamic.
Like, literally they're
like, can we have a yes day?
We've had so many yes days.
- Good.
So, well this is the same producing team.
We started this process while we were on
set making 'Yes day'.
We were just like,
oh, what else can we can,
what else can we do?
It's also loosely comes from
an Amy Krouse Rosenthal book,
which she, bless her soul,
also wrote 'Yes Day'.
This was 'Bedtime for Mommy',
about a little girl
putting her mom to bed,
her parents to bed, and
they don't wanna go to bed.
And they're, we want
another glass of water.
We want this.
So it's just kind of that switching idea.
- Yeah.
I love it.
Yeah, my kids are gonna be
obsessed with this one too.
I'm wondering what,
'cause there's like a dance,
an annual dance thing
that your character does.
- There's a dance, yeah, there's a dance.
Everyone will be doing it.
We have Beth Nicely came
and choreographed for us.
And it is, she's a former
Rockette, a Broadway dancer.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Jennifer] And we had a blast,
all except for Ed Helms.
- Bless you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he didn't dance?
- He danced.
Oh no, he danced.
He should get credit
for every single step.
He just was like, this is awful.
(Kelly laughs)
I am so miserable.
But he worked so, so hard.
- [Kelly] Well that's the best tease.
Now we wanna tease.
Between takes, I would look back
and we'd be shooting something
weeks away from the dance
and he would have his nose facing a wall,
just like 5, 6, 7, 8.
Yeah.
- Just wanting to nail it.
- Yep, just wanting to get through.
Do you have your own like
family traditions like that?
'Cause we have, I literally
just had a dance party
to share his new Christmas song,
DJ play a Christmas song,
'cause it's the greatest
Christmas song ever.
But we had one last night at my house.
We have dance parties all the time.
Do you do anything like that in house?
- Oh yeah,
I mean we do all kinds of things.
During COVID I talked to my
kids into making videos with me.
- [Kelly] Sure.
- And.
- [Kelly] Nothing else to do.
- It was so, they were so fun.
And then they kind of got
that I was more into them than they were.
And that was it.
- [Kelly] Then it became not cool.
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
Then it was not cool anymore.
And then they were like pulled the,
but yes, this, this character
has an annual Christmas song
and dance video that they do
for Christmas as their Christmas card.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's so great.
- Well, Jennifer is
also a founding investor
of the Angel City Football Club.
The women's soccer team in
Los Angeles, which is so cool.
(audience applauds and cheers)
But I think that's awesome,
we're gonna get to that.
But here she's at another soccer match.
Here you go.
(background chatter)
- [Jennifer] Nice.
(Yelling in the background)
(audience applauds and cheers)
- You're the one yelling?
- [Jennifer] I'm the one yelling.
- You were yelling.
- I'm yelling like I suddenly
know what's happening,
just 'cause I'm an investor in Angel City.
It's like I go to Angel
City, I'm clueless.
I know I'm clueless.
I just am smiling, having a good time.
- [Kelly] I know, I get like this.
- Bits and pieces, you know,
I mean, Abby Wambach and Glennon Doyle.
They tell me things.
- I love them by the way.
- [Jennifer] Aren't they cool?
- Yes.
- [Jennifer] I know.
So I'm learning.
I'm there a lot.
But as soon as I'm out
and I'm like my nephew's
game in West Virginia,
I'm suddenly an expert,
yelling things, you know.
Hey ref, that's a yellow card.
I don't know.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love the people at the
game are like, is that, no?
Like, they're like.
- [Jennifer] I grew up
with everyone at the game.
- That's high school.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay,
so they're used to you being this close.
- [Jennifer] That's my town.
- Oh, that's awesome.
- [Jennifer] Yeah, they all know me.
They are not impressed.
(audience laugh)
- [Kelly] Family is like a movie.
That's awesome.
They're not impressed down there.
Well, we're gonna play a game next.
Are you ready?
- I know.
- [Kelly] Well you always beat me.
You always beat me at games.
- You are very competitive.
- [Kelly] I am very competitive.
- I'm ready.
- I'm okay if I lose, but
I wanna compete heavily.
- [Jennifer] Yeah, okay, all right,
let me get ready.
- [Kelly] All right, let's take a break.
All right, we're gonna stretch it out.
Jennifer's movie, 'Family
Switch' is on Netflix right now
and we've got the perfect
game to honor it next.
We'll be right back.